avec nous sophie boulanger qui est pdg
cofondatrice de bon look et gilles
fortin co fondateur de l'entreprise
trista bonsoir à vous deux alors quel
est l'objectif de votre front commun
monsieur fortin d'abord ce soir
écoutez on voulait faire contre le parti
un lob qui a été signé par des experts
qui disait que tant qu'à y est ou ce
bien fermé pendant un temps des fêtes
alors on voulait que le premier ministre
legault a au moins le deuxième côté de
la médaille
et qu'on lui dise les vraies chief a
livré chiffres c'est pas compliqué vous
les avez tout donné on est à l'heure je
donne chez tristan par exemple il y en a
pas eu de contamination ni au siège
social ni au centre de distribution ni à
nos usines de farnham 0 corps et dans
les dix ans et contesté dans les
boutiques nous prenons nos zéros
employés qui a été contaminé sur les
lieux de travail donc encore pas
contaminer persan il parmi les clients
séquence il y avait des clients
contaminé il peut pas avoir contaminé
notre personnel comment vous savez que
les clients n'ont pas pu être contaminé
en se rendant dans vos boutiques ou dans
les centres d'achats monde à 0 employés
qui étaient contaminés et pts et je veux
que la liste des trafics de chez tristan
depuis que l'ouverture des centres
d'achats effet depuis le mois de mai il
ya eu et cucq théologie tout ça en
dépendent matic j'ai voulu copier pour
pas vous donner des chiffres en larmes
j'ai voulu leur copie manuellement il
actionné avec ma calculette 1714 1142
clients qui sont en friche et tristan
depuis le mois de mai j'ai zéro
contamination françois roberge 9
millions sans et minent ses hôtes a
dynamité autant on parle de dizaines de
millions de visites et on vous rabâche
sans corps mais si on faisait ça
françois legault là sans cov sur deux
fois la population du québec
il s' est aux anges oui mais seulement
mais quatre autres c'est en sept mois
madame boulanger et comment ça se passe
dans vos magasins
oui non
des statistiques 6000 ans mathis temps
nous ont suivis règle 5 pack d'avants
très strictes sont établis en trop par
les autres confessions est lourde et
obtient également les recteurs en place
par le gouvernement dont on l'espère
continuera ce que monsieur fortin dit
nous on j'ai sorti mon style et les
stars d'aujourd'hui dont 439 milite
depuis la réouverture et zéro cas de
transmission nous prenez l'aquila en
train on fonctionne ce rendez vous
uniquement à 5 stylos d'avoir trouve
mandat magasin et un chez chaque client
d'un boulanger chaque client vous savez
qu'ils n'ont pas été infectés par la
copie de neuf donc nous on prend les
informations de chacun de nos clients
et c'est arrivé à cinq reprises qu'on
ait eu d envoyer qui nous ont indiqué
qu'ils étaient exécutés dans notre top
protocole en place de pair avec la santé
publique régionale delà de la région en
question qui ont raté elle tous nos
clients ont réussi à tout qui ont été
présents la même journée quels employés
n'ont pas faim suivie et personnes
aguerries et analysées aux contamines et
donc ce que vous dites c'est que vous ne
méritez pas dans les circonstances de
fermer monsieur fortin même fermé
pendant le temps des fêtes où il ya
beaucoup d'activités qui vont ralentir
quand même pendant le temps des fêtes et
compte tenu du coût que le gouvernement
dit qu'il faudrait donner pour essayer
de la tuer cette deuxième vague là est
ce que ce serait pas quand même un
effort supplémentaire à faire
on est d'accord mais qui donne les coups
là où ça va porter s'ils donnent un coup
son nous ôter que ça donne rien à quoi
bon le faire c'est la période la plus
occupée elle voyait moins occupés on
sait les gens ont pas alors il ya tous
les éléments de notre personnel qui
endurent ce depuis sept mois à se
disputer leur lait leur monoxyde de
carbone à geaune élan et là en plus on
voit émerger chômage deux semaines avant
noël
écoutez le gouvernement il ya un exemple
à toronto toronto a fermé l'autoroute 85
turn your d'air est ce que les colons b6
fatwa semaine ça se verrait
ne pas de changement c'est pas là que ça
parle donc c'est un coup d'épée dans
l'eau
madame boulanger pour vous selon vous un
coup d'épée dans l'eau qui aurait
quelles conséquences financières pour
votre entreprise
donc ils commençaient les conséquences
enfin d'un million de dollars récupérés
par la suite puis un peu pour ça et qu
est-ce que monsieur fortin disait
l'elysée qu'on respecte sont très
strictes aucune donnée à l'appui que on
est des vecteurs de communication de
contamination pardon donc nous ce qu'on
demande c'est de rester boire il y aussi
le vélo je rate les mots qui avait été
donné par david bensadoun des taux dans
une autre entrevue mentionné donc
évidemment quand les commerces ferment
comme les commerces
j'ai essentiels qui reste ouvert pour
soi les grands bailleurs sont à majorité
propriété américaine
et c'est souvent la cohue dans ces
commerces là donc les gens arrêtent pas
vous savez de consommer et d'acheter ils
vont plutôt se retrouver en masse ainsi
qu'aux personnes en france pour que nous
savons que ça va donner c'est ce que le
nouvelliste redit il y aura beaucoup
plus de contraventions et il faut
respecter les consignes et c'est comme
ça qu'on va réduire réduire justement la
contamination si les gens respectent les
règles est ce que monsieur fortin vous
êtes d'accord avec une approche plus
coercitives totalement monsieur fillion
et puis si le gouvernement pense de
renflouer ses coffres avec des
contraventions d'un centre commercial
il va voir les vaches maigres parce que
tout le monde est sur les nerfs tout le
monde fait attention plus que les
directives qui sont donnés ont fait on
on a le résultat d'un bon travail qui
est fait on dit pas qu'il ya pas de co
vide on dit qu'on fait extrêmement
attention et qu'on suit les directives
et qu on les dépasse
alors s'ils pensent qu'on est épicé de
tout coeur qu'on n'a pas avec cela il
n'a pas tiqué quand on dit on dépasse
tout le temps leurs exigences lily nsp
que je regardais les échos aujourd'hui
parce que je sais que vous avez vous
donné qu'il ya pas de problème avec les
chefs que vous donnez je peux faire une
guerre de chiffres
mais un aspect qu dit que dans les 1000
les milieux de travail dans les milieux
de travail de 12 % des cas actuellement
des éclosions active
c'est dans le commerce de détail et 1,1
pour cent dans les vêtements et les
chaussures dans les boutiques de
vêtements et de chaussures
ce qui demeure extrêmement faible par
rapport à l'ensemble des milieux de
travail
si on vous demande de fermer madame
boulanger vous allez donc fermé ben oui
évidemment on va suivre les règles en
place
si les diamants désolant pour nous
centaine d'employés qui sont dans nos
boutiques et dès que les gens du bureau
chef et je me suis certain écoutez je
pense qu'on est le meilleur trio de
christian dubé
people&baby puis françois legault pour
le plan d'édition et on notre confiance
totale
si c'était des joies du rock et on
aurait la coupe stanley alors si nous
demande ferme et on va fermer
mais moi je me fais à leur intelligence
la chasse peut pas une décision comme ça
parfait c'est ce qu'on verra dans les
prochains jours à vous deux merci et
bonne chance pour la suite
merci